good morning believe nation today's
message is print your own money over to
you Ron Finley growing one plant will
give you a thousand ten thousand seeds
okay when one dollars worth of green
beans will give you like $75 where for
produce it's like my it's my gospel and
I'm telling people grow your own food
we're on your own foods like print your
own money all right thank you this is an
important message because you know run
feeling is a gardener so he's thinking
in gardening terms you plant the seed
you water it you nurture it and it grows
and it creates something you can sell
for real money but it also applies to
being an entrepreneur right as an
entrepreneur you have an idea that's
your seed you need to nurture it you
need to give it water you need to give
it sunlight you need to give it
nutrition so that it flourishes and
grows that it grows its roots breaks to
the ground and then create something
that eventually you can make a lot of
money with where a lot of entrepreneurs
they don't give their idea enough of
that nurturing they don't let enough
time for the roots to grow and for the
momentum to build and you kill your idea
before it's really had a chance to break
through the ground and take off and turn
into something that can make you a lot
of money so remember your idea is
something I need to be nurtured on a
daily basis you got to take care of it
you got to look after it you are
continue to water it and help it grow
and if you do that consistently every
single day you're likely to build
something that will print you a lot of
money believe so my question the day
today is how do you nurture your
business and your idea what do you do
consistently I want to know what you do
every day or every week to help your
idea and help your business flourish
leave in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out what you guys are up
to thank you so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of an espresso